the president of the european commission
ozil from the lion has urged pharma
company astrazeneca
to stick by its commitments to supply
the eu with its kovit-19 vaccine
her comments come after the british
swedish firm said it was
cutting the number of doses for the eu
by 60 percent
because of production problems the drug
maker also said it was
not contractually obliged to deliver but
fonder line said the contract is quote
crystal clear in response the eu is
taking steps to allow it to prevent
the export of vaccines from the eu if
need be
the controversy comes as the block faces
pressure with many countries failing to
meet
their vaccination targets
well our correspondent george matas in
brussels knows more about all this
there's a new offer on the table from
astrazeneca what can you tell us
exactly gerard there are reports
unconfirmed reports i have to say that
an extra offer of
some 8 million vaccine doses has come in
from astrazeneca
there's also reports about some other
concessions that have been made by the
pharmaceutical giant frankly if you look
at the numbers and the 60 percent
uh cut that astrazeneca has announced
it will still take us to only half the
doses that were promised
and there's a number of pressing
questions you know where have the doses
gone that the eu has pre-financed
and why actually uh is this uh cut uh
affecting europe and not other countries
like like the uk those questions are
uh still unanswered so you mentioned the
okay
the uk and and they get the doses that
they uh pre-ordered
that's part of the dispute isn't it
absolutely that's part of the dispute
and the ceo of astrazeneca
has explained that the reason for that
is that the deal with the uk has been
done earlier
that in that contract with the uk it's
foreseen that the two factories in the
uk
only cater to the uk and not to the eu
but the eu reasoning
is that no such hierarchy of uh
company sites no hierarchy or or no
priority
of of deployment of vaccines is foreseen
in the contract
they have been given and also the point
that the ceo of astrazeneca made about
best practice
it doesn't count for the eu for the eu
that's a lame excuse
they say there is a clear commitment and
that is why they hope the company will
publish
the this particular contract today for
everyone to see
that the promises that have been made to
the eu are unfulfilled
so did the eu not know that the
uk would have a priority and uh
is is was there a lack of due diligence
on the uh on the eu's part or should
astra have told them
from from the perspective of the eu
there is a lack of information
the the key issue for them is that if
you cut
the vaccine supply that was promised by
contract
by more than half by 60 percent you need
to come up with
some really good reasons for that and
those reasons haven't been given
apparently there is a problem in the
supply chain
on the european side in a factory in
belgium
but from the perspective of the eu the
astrazeneca is a global company they're
producing as far away as india
and if they have supply problems that
burden needs to be shared
by all the countries that they are
handing out their vaccines to
and it can't be that the biggest
customer which is the eu
only carries the burden well new
measures are now being introduced at
least being discussed today that
could see an export ban of doses
from the eu uh is that a tit-for-tat
move
well first of all that that would be the
most radical uh
step if you want what the eu is
currently doing is
is basically flexing their muscles to
show uh astrazeneca
that they do mean mean business uh when
it when it comes
that they're not taken for fools uh if
you want
uh we'll we'll still have to see to
whether it will lead actually to an
export ban and for the moment officials
here
rule that out what they want is is not
vaccine nationalism as some in the uk
have put it but what they want is to
fair treatment
and to monitor whether the treatment is
fair and according to the contract
that is why they will introduce this
transparency mechanism today
where the eu can monitor to what extent
vaccines that are being produced on
european soil
are leaving the eu george
is there in brussels thank you george
germany's health minister jens spahn has
welcomed the astrazeneca off of a
further
8 million vaccine doses to the eu but
speaking this morning
he also underlined that the european
union has paid for
and is entitled to the originally
promised 80 million doses
the european union member states have
invested jointly in the pre-production
of these vaccines
so they also have a right to profit from
that it's a profit
but this is not about europe first it's
about a fair
allocation for the european union
german health uh minister and speaking
there now dw's chief political
correspondent melinda crane
is in berlin melinda we heard the german
health minister there
what else did he say well he just spoke
to
a press conference and said that he
knows that germany's rollout of the
vaccine
has been problematic and he understands
people's impatience
but the fact is that difficult weeks
still do lie ahead
he also mentioned the vaccine summit
that the government will be holding on
monday saying that that
would be looking to improve coordination
on the vaccine
between the federal states and the
federal government here in berlin
he said nonetheless progress is being
made especially in the vaccination of
vulnerable groups and that the
government still hopes to reach
its target of offering the vaccine to
all
people in care facilities elderly care
facilities by the middle
of february and finally he said that as
of march he expects the situation will
ease not only because of the astrozenica
vaccine then becoming available but also
two further
vaccines that are in the pipeline so
that he still believes germany can meet
at school
of offering vaccines to all who want
them by the end of the summer
so vaccination being one side of the
story uh containment is
another where germany is planning to
close the borders now
for some countries tell us more about
that
that's correct uh germany's interior
minister said yesterday
that as soon as today the government may
announce a plan
to essentially shut down travel from
five countries
where the new mutations are known to be
prevalent so that would be brazil
britain ireland portugal and
south africa there had been talk earlier
this week of possibly shutting off air
travel altogether that is not the case
it would be limited to these
five countries and apparently there
would be exceptions for german citizens
returning
from those places as well as for people
who work in
the freight industry wcw's chief
political correspondent melinda crane
reporting
results from large-scale trials in the
uk suggest
another new vaccine could soon be
available
u.s pharmaceutical company novavax has
said its coronavirus vaccine
given in two doses is almost 90 percent
effective
the firm has applied for regulatory
approval in the uk
novovac scientists began working on a
covid19
cure one year ago rapid progress meant
it wasn't long before human trials were
underway
now efficacy tests have shown their hard
work has paid off
with a vaccine that is 89 effective
even against the new uk variant of the
virus
i think the other bit of news uh that
comes through is that there is slightly
different levels of efficacy
against the different strains the
variants you've been hearing about
that's not surprising uh but it is just
a little message that we are going to
see
some degree of variation of protection
against these variants
a separate trial in south africa showed
the inoculation had just under 50
percent efficacy
against the new variant this is rampant
there
novavac says it's already working on a
booster to try and improve that
british prime minister boris johnson
welcomed the headline news and said the
uk
had ordered 60 million doses the
european union has ordered 200 million
it's the fourth vaccine to seek approval
from western regulators
though doses are not expected to be
ready until later this year
good time to have a look at some other
developments in the coronavirus pandemic
the makers of russia's sputnik 5 vaccine
have
said they can provide 100 million doses
to the eu
hungary is the only country in the block
to have approved the russian jab
mexico has surpassed india as the
country with the third highest covet 19
death toll
over 155 000 have died there
and the united nations has called 2020
the worst
year in tourism history with global
losses of more than one
trillion euros
the united nations secretary general is
calling the distribution of covet 19
vaccines a quote
global emergency secretary general
antonio guterres
said more than 70 million doses have
been administered worldwide
but fewer than 20 000 vaccinations were
on the african continent
the uh warned that while every country
has the duty to protect its own people
no country can afford to neglect the
rest of the world
this is a global crisis science is
succeeding
but solidarity is failing it's about
fair distribution
not only about money
fair access to coronavirus vaccines
around the globe
that's what the european union promised
the world
even before the first vaccine was
approved
the eu has invested heavily in research
and development and member states have
put millions into helping poor nations
acquire
vaccines in the future but as the world
scrambles to produce and distribute
enough
jabs in the end it seems europe does
come
first if you can't help that's fine
ronda's former health minister anees
biwangwawa tells me
but then don't cast yourself as a savior
be frank
and say my people first don't lie to me
and say
we will be equal well so so because we
start to prepare in ronda we are
prepared
but we just say that your word we cannot
count on it
and that's not good while the
coronavirus continues to spread rapidly
in africa
only a few countries there have begun
immunizing their citizens
egypt ordered vaccines from china for
example and guinea is rolling out a
russian vaccine
these two world powers were quicker off
the mark than the eu
they are practicing uh vaccine diplomacy
for to uh meet their uh foreign policy
objectives
but in the meantime we need to look at
the outcomes right you know if it helped
right
mitigate you know these the uh access
gap
between poor and rich nations why not
even europe's closest neighbors in the
western balkans have yet to see the
block deliver on pledges to help
here too chinese and russian vaccines
are filling devoid
the european union have said they wanted
it to be a global public good they
wanted to ensure equitable access but
we're just seeing even today and
yesterday
them you know suggesting or threatening
that there might be
export bans on the coronavirus vaccines
produced in the eu
and so obviously that's very concerning
sign of vaccine nationalism
here in brussels officials say
humanitarian vaccine donations will be
exempt from tougher export controls
they promise help will come soon to say
that the eu is not doing anything i
think it's
is is is is really not correct we are
actually in discussion both with the
member states
but also with the pharmaceutical
companies in order precisely to
help this advance the eu was quick to
call for global cooperation against a
pandemic
but so far it's been too slow to live up
to promises of global solidarity
you